السلام عليكم ورحمه الله هذا موجز الاخبار
من الجزيره قال رئيس هيئه الطاقه الذريه
الايرانيه ان من حق الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه تفتيش مراكز تخصيب
اليورانيوم على ان يتم ذلك وفق اتفاق
وقوانين محدده من نجهته لفا المتحدث باسم
الهيئه ان تكون طهران والوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه اتفقتها على تركيب كاميرات
مراقبه جديده في المنشات النوويه واكد ان
ملفات تخصيب اليورانيوم بنسبه اربعه
وثمانين في المئه قد اغلق
في المقابل انتقد رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
بنيامين نتنياهو تصريحات مدير الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه التي قال فيها اين
تنفيذه هجوم على منشات نوويه غير قانوني
وعقل نتنياهو
بالتصريحات غير مناسبه مضيفا ان بلاده
ستواصل العمل من اجل منع ايران من حيازه
اسلحه نوويه
مثل الجيش الاوكراني اي انسحاب جماعي
لقوته من مدينه باخموت شرقيه اوكرانيا
وعقل المتحدث باسم المجموعه الشرقيه
للقوات الاوكرانيه ان الجيش الاوكراني لا
يزال يسيطر على المدينه رغم صعوبه الوضع
مضيفا ان القتال يدور بشكل اساسي في
ضواحيها
في هذه الاثناء التقى وزير الدفاع الروسيه
عددا من قاده الوحدات المقاتله الروسيه
المتمركزه في ما تسميه روسيا من طاقه
العمليه العسكريه الخاصه باوكرانيا وبحث
مع قاده العمليات دعم خطوط الانتاج وتهيئه
الظروف اللازمه للنشر الامن للجنود
قالت المتحدثه باسم القياده عمليه الجنوب
الاوكرانيه ان روسيا تواصل والاستعداد
لهجمات صاروخيه محتمله
ولتوجيه ضربات الدقيقه ومحدده لاوكرانيا
مؤكده ان روسيا غيرت من تكتيكاتها
من جهاته شدد المتحدث باسم القوات الجويه
الاوكرانيه على ضروره الحصول على مقاتلات
حديثه ومنظومات دفاع جوي لمواجهه ضربات
الروسيه
قال مؤسس شركه فاجنر العسكريه ان الشرطه
العسكريه الروسيه اعاقت وصول اشخاص انضموا
حديثا لقواته الى مركز فاجنر العسكري
واوضح ان الشرطه العسكريه منعت وصوله
اولئك المنضمين الى قوته ووزعتهم بين
وحدات اخرى وقال ان عند ذاته الذخيره
المخصصه لقواته لم تصل اليها اما بسبب
البيروقراطيه او الخيانه وفق تعبيره
شهدت العاصمه التونسيه مظاهرات نحتاجيه
نظمتها جبهه الخلاص المعارضه للمطالبه
باطلاق سراح المعتقلين السياسيين ورفع
المتظاهرون الشعارات تدعو الى اسقاط ما
يصفونه بالانقلاب واحترام حقوق الانسان
وقالت وزاره الداخليه انه رغم عدم امتثال
الجهه المنظمه لقرار عدم الموافقه على
مسامته تحركا احتجاجيا فانه جرى تامين
المظاهرات
اشكركم على متابعه الموجز انما كنتم طابت
اوقاتكم بكل خير